geehrte Damen und Herren ich darf Sie
recht herzlich hier in der
maria-theresien-kaserne in Wien begrüßen
zum heutigen Pressegespräch mit der
Verteidigungsministerin Claudia Danner
und mit der Bundesministerin für Frauen
Familie Integration und Medien Susanne
Raaber
ich darf die Verteidigungsministerin um
ihre Worte suchen
vielen Dank Herrmann sehr geehrte Frau
Bundesministerin sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren der Medien ich glaube dass ein
ganz besonderer tagungsbevorsteht morgen
nämlich der Girls Day ein besonderer Tag
deshalb weil alle jungen Frauen die
Möglichkeit haben werden das erste Mal
einen praktischen und persönlichen
Einblick in den Bundesdienst zu bekommen
und gerade wir im Bundesheer haben ja
regelmäßig bei den BesucherInnen höchst
Zahlen bei denjenigen die interessiert
sind sich über das Berufsbild Soldatin
zu informieren denn wenn wir uns ganz
ehrlich sind als junge Frau als junges
Mädchen weiß man sehr oft nicht konkret
was einem beim Bundesheer erwartet wie
auch der Alltag einer Soldatin ausschaut
und sie daher vielleicht diese
Berufsmöglichkeit und eine Karriere beim
Bundesheer gar nicht so sehr in Erwägung
daher finde ich diesen Tag ganz
besonders und an Dich war
Bundesministerin ein ganz großes
Dankeschön dass ich hier jedes Jahr
zahlreiche Frauen zusammen finden können
die sich eben informieren über die
verschiedenen Karriere Möglichkeiten ja
und in diesem Jahr werden es ganz
besonders viele sein gerade hier in der
Maria theresien-kaserne erwarten wir
1600 junge Frauen das ist der momentane
Stand den wir der militärkommandante von
Wien und oberstreisner von der Garde so
eben mitgeteilt haben also 1600 junge
Mädchen und Frauen die sich für den
Beruf der Soldatin interessieren in
allen Kasernen sind es natürlich noch
viel mehr das sind 5 tausende zum
jetzigen Zeitpunkt die sich ja
informieren werden und ich glaube das
ist durchaus eine Bestätigung dass wir
im Resort jungen Frauen sehr
interessante berufliche Möglichkeiten
bieten können wir haben auch dieses Jahr
etwas Neues noch gemacht wir haben die
Geburten Jahrgänge 2003 bis 2006
persönlich eingeladen um eben das
bundesjahr zu erleben und sie in
weiterer Folge für uns zu gewinnen ja
wir feiern 25 Jahre ersten April 1998
war es soweit 11 freuen sind beim
Bundesheer eingerückt und mussten sich
in einer Männerdomäne beweisen es hat
sich dieser Frauenanteil stetig zwar
erhöht aber und liegt momentan bei 645
Soldatinnen aber da ist das Ziel noch
lange nicht erreicht für uns weil wir
wollen die Frauenquote im Bundesheer
weiter erhöhen und wir werden ein ganz
besonderes Augenmerk auch auf die
Vereinbarkeit von Familie und Beruf
legen wir haben Frau Ministerin hier
schon einiges gemacht was
Kinderbetreuungsmöglichkeiten und den
Ausbau anbelangt wir haben sehr viele
auch Fördermaßnahmen im Sinne von
Mentoring Programmen auch gesetzt für
Soldatinnen und es gibt regelmäßige
AbsolventInnen treffen bei unserer
heeresunteroffiziersakademie bei der
Landesverteidigungsakademie also
Vernetzungsmöglichkeiten wo die
Soldatinnen sich auch austauschen können
ja und das ganz neue dass wir die ersten
April gestartet ist also genau nach 25
Jahren ist die Möglichkeit Freiwilligen
grundwertdienst für Frauen eben
abzuleisten und damit haben wir eine
Schwelle eine eingeschwelle wieder
gesenkt weil die jungen Frauen genauso
wie der junge Mann bei einer unserer
sechs stellungsstraßen eine
Orientierungsphase nach Durchlaufen der
Stellung dann eben haben können und da
die Möglichkeit haben den soldatenberuch
kennenzulernen wir sind eine
einzigartige Arbeitgeber das sind wir
als Bundesdienst ohne Zweifel und das
sind wir auch als österreichisches
Bundesheer Frauen und Männer verdienen
gleich viel das ist eine
Selbstverständlichkeit wie ihre
männlichen Kollegen und sammeln ganz
offen in der Privatwirtschaft ist das
nach wie vor leider nicht der Fall und
wir wollen auch zeigen welche Karrieren
man bei uns beim Bundesheer eben machen
kann ich glaube dass der Girls Day und
der Freiwillige grundwehrdienste für
Frauen interessierten Mädchen und Frauen
die Möglichkeit ergibt uns als
Bundesheer näher kennenzulernen und ich
glaube wir wünschen uns beide dass wir
viele junge Frauen für den Beruf der
Soldatin begeistern können ich freue
mich dann im Anschluss schon auf
spannende Gespräche und einen Austausch
zum morgigen Girls Day danke schön
danke sehr sehr geehrte Frau
Bundesminister ich würde sie nun um ihre
Worte suchen ja vielen Dank zu allererst
einmal an dich auf Bundesministerin dass
wir heute hier sein dürfen dass ich
heute hier sein darf bei Euch zu Gast
beim Bundesheer das ist für mich ja
nicht das erste Mal und jedes Mal
unglaublich inspirierend besonders weil
ich immer die tollen Soldatinnen und
Soldatinnen treffen darf und man hier
einfach sieht mit wie viel Mut ihr diese
Frau noch hier vorangegangen sind im
Aufbrechen von klassischen Rollenbildern
und ihm Aufbrechen von Klischees wenn es
darum geht das gewisse Dinge einfach
gewisse Berufe Männerberufe sind und ich
bin unglaublich beeindruckt was in den
letzten Jahren hier gelungen ist wenn es
darum geht Frauen für das Bundesheer zu
begeistern es ist ein eine große
Auszeichnung dass morgen eine so große
Anzahl an Frauen hier beim Bundesheer
sein wird ich glaube eine so große
Anzahl
gab es ja noch nie und das freut mich
natürlich sehr von von mir geht als Frau
Ministerin jährlich die Initiative aus
den Girls die im Bundestag
abzu im Bundesdienst abzuhalten viele
Ministerien
beteiligen sich an dieser Initiative
Gott sei Dank und glücklicherweise
werden die Türen geöffnet der Häuser um
eben Mädchen für gewisse Berufsbranchen
auch zu begeistern und mein Ziel ist
dabei die Mädchen vor allem zu
begeistern für Berufe die man vielleicht
nicht an die man vielleicht nicht
klassischerweise denkt wo man sich
vielleicht denkt das wäre nichts für
mich weil das ist ein Beruf in dem
primär sind das wäre nicht für mich weil
Technik
Naturwissenschaften Mathematik oder gar
ein Dienst beim Bundesheer das das mag
ich gar nicht zu denken weil da kennt
man nur die klassischen Bilder der
Männer in diesem Berufen ich bin davon
überzeugt dass die Zeit wo es reine
Männerberufe gibt einfach vorbei ist ich
will und ich bin froh dass wir dieses
Anliegen einfach so zutiefst teilen dass
jedes Mädchen
anhand ihre Interessen sein Interessen
entscheiden kann was es wird und dass
alle Berufswege für alle Mädchen auch
offenstehen
morgen wird ein Bundesheer ein
großartiger Tag dann auch in anderen
Ressorts bei mir im Bundeskanzleramt wir
werden natürlich auch die Türen des
Hauses öffnen es wird dort es werden
dort viele Mädchen auch sein die eben
mit
Naturwissenschaften mit Mathematik mit
diesen klassischen Mint Berufen auch in
Berührung kommen sollen wir werden
gemeinsam Experimente machen und ich es
ist für mich einer der schönsten Tage im
Jahr und ich freue mich sehr darauf
abseits von Initiativen im Bundesheer
gibt es natürlich auch weitere
Initiativen die genau das bezwecken
wollen Mädchen für sogenannte atypische
Berufe zu begeistern unter anderem habe
ich letztes Jahr einen Fond gegründet
der heißt leer letzt im Power Austria
und da geht es darum dass wir die
großartigen Frauen die bereits
vorangegangen sind in einem vielleicht
nicht so leichten Unfälle in einem
männerdominierten Umfeld vor den Vorhang
holen und mit diesen Vorbildern mit
diesen rollmodels auch in die Schule
gehen und ich möchte dass deshalb so
explizit hervorheben weil eines dieser
rollmodel und einer dieser Powerfrauen
eben auch eine Offizierin aus dem
österreichischen Bundesheer ist Silvia
spirandio die hier auch das Bundesheer
mit einer sehr großen Leidenschaft immer
wieder den Mädchen auch in den Schulen
näher bringt das finde ich einfach ganz
großartig und das hat mich das Feuer
zuletzt auch wieder sozusagen angesteckt
und deshalb bin ich davon überzeugt dass
es auch morgen gelingen wird beim Girls
die hier viele Mädchen dafür zu
begeistern wir haben heute
sehr windige Situation aber wir haben
Rückenwind für die Stärkung von Frauen
und nicht Gegenwind und ich möchte mich
noch einmal ganz herzlich bei Dir liebe
Frau Bundesministerin bedanken weil es
ist nun mal so
dass Frauenpolitik nicht allein aus dem
frauenresort herausgemacht werden kann
sondern es ist unser aller Aufgabe dass
wir gemeinsam an der Gleichstellung von
Männern und Frauen arbeiten in
Österreich
da braucht es einen starken
Schulterschluss innerhalb der Regierung
und da braucht es auch mutige Frauen die
hier den Weg bereiten für die nächste
Generation und ich glaube da kämpfen wir
Seite an Seite dafür vielen Dank
danke für die Ausführungen gibt es
Fragen
je nachdem es keine Fragen mehr gibt
darf ich mich recht herzlich für die
Pressekonferenz bedanken und wünsche uns
allen morgen einen wunderschönen
Girlsday danke